you have been a staple of the New York
comedy scene for so long and people love
your work
I'm thinking why is it taking us so long
to get you on this show has there been
some kind of an issue yeah yeah it's
probably the reason I'm sitting here
with you and not over there telling
jokes
I am inherently filthy you have a you
have a you have I've always heard that
you were absolutely hysterical and our
people have been trying to get you on
the show for a long time and they said
there's literally not one joke that you
could tell on television
no none Peter got involved last time I
heard about that I heard it Peter got
angry with you which shocks me they have
such a good sense of humor yeah yeah
well you know I said to find out today
that I even know how much I train I'll
never be or have enough cardio to be as
funny as Andy Samberg I mean man that
was breathing heavy no no it cost it
took him his entire first segment
talking to catch his breath so they did
do this that was me me and you I'd be
leaning over like this rag on my neck
yeah yeah
you